khi ăn lập cần sớp trong camera, phật mỗi, dám xác khắp thịp vũeng.
Saan nghe hai người lâm thẳng mười nha hai gảnh cũng chăm hai người thư,
trong ăn tỉnh nghĩ ăn, tổ chức chỉ đạo đại già,
nghiệp thương kiếp tổ thịt thịt thịt thịt thịt thịt thịt thịt thịt thịt thịt thịt thịt thịt,
à tản gió tôn chế biệp bản thịt vũeng để bước vào bật lộng chí thức.
Hệ thường giám sát Anh Ninh có hơn 6,3 camera tại hợp 4 chăm triếng mới điểm, trải điều dộm khắp trên đẹp bản thệ của Vinh.
Trong đó, tập trúc tại các lúc xong thông, nhiều vòng sướng, đã ba đã thương các tuyện đường triếng đổi thiện, các tuyện dạo thông trong điểm và các buộc tiêu quan trọng.
Đây là chúng tập trị vì hiện đại, đồng bộ nhất hiện nay, tất cả hệ thống camera và hệ thống khoảng trị phần mềm, dưới liệu, đều tích hợp, sự giúp công nghệ trị tệ dân tạo,
nhìn dễ tìm kiếm tâm mình, phù hợp vấn công nghệ mối bối trìm không? Trong đó, có một số tính năng tắt dụng quan trọng của hệ thống nhiều truyvét lưới tượng,
thích là tích hợp bố trợ phương án bảo vệ vụ tiêu, sẽ đại và thức phương án đã bảo anh nịch trở tự khác.
Tất kìm sát thật địp kìm sát đặc biệt phương tiện, có trở đà bảo trở tự át tòa ra thông,
thích hiện lỗi và phục phục công tắc sự lý vị thạm ra thông.